[Music]
you're having a good day thank you for
joining I already see and the live chat
there's a lot of talks and I see
countdown going that down by Jake lovely
alright well today we are gonna try and
talk about some of the rule of his stuff
with white because I was really afraid
to start playing Roy Lopez and I just I
was a big fan of scotch and four night
so I thought it's nice to look into
something different for a change so I
really enjoyed this line with Queen e2
for example I'm gonna dive in really
fast cuz I really I have these three
games that I'd really want to show you
and today we don't have two hours we
only have one so just sayin
alright so hi Peter oh hi Nixon so I fit
black I played d6 so seeing how to play
d6 was interesting for me like how would
White play it but right now I want to
show you more about the main line with
96 so the idea is like for example with
Knight f6 you know there are a lot of
different ideas with whites right whitey
and just castle wise can just do c3 d4 a
lot of different stuff so what I started
to look into is Queen e2 and I really
liked it and I would still try it again
and I really like it's definitely one of
my recommend
Asians oh hi ms7 cool I remember you
I liked South Africa was very nice was
there 2014 thank you a mod yep
the chemistry exam did go quite well I
have another one on Monday all right
back to the chasis stuff so here black
has different possibilities there is a
Bishop e7 than someone play e5 with me
so let's look at Bishop e7 first there
are three of these three are my personal
games that I played actually all three
of them in 2017 and I believe all three
of them were with opponents same rating
or slightly lower so I thought that
would be a nice try so the main idea is
with Queen c2 with Queen on e - when you
play b5 it's already a target as I will
show you in the games that I played and
it's like you were already preparing to
use that palm while confusing your
opponent a little bit so I really like
that aspect of it
so here let's say you do your normal c3
and Bishop comes to b3 and normal castle
and you immediately do your rook e1
going for d4 you're doing everything
very logical developing getting your
pieces out and yeah marshal attack is
also possible I'm gonna show you in
another game that I had tto and hi Anand
alright so
she went c4 I believe this was I think
this was the female opponent that I had
yeah I played her in Parag but the names
are a little hard to pronounce sleeve
sleepy sleepy cough she I believe she
was pulled
yeah she she was from Poland she is from
Poland so alright and I think she was
she is younger than me so that was fun
all right so I got my D for now question
for the audience what do you want to do
with whites do you want to think take
something push something develop
something so first question of the day
so quiet
or if you have other candidate moves
please feel free to share them too
all right so next one wants d5 very nice
Alfred wants to develop Marcin wants to
keep the pressure we do have an h3
recommendation 92 d5 hmm
all right so tt0 you were right if like
police Bishop e7 d5 is nice but also
here d5 is doable especially because
this is something that you can't do
Knight teach you right now if 92 just
simply take and the pawn is kind of
blocked so the ideal h3
I think h3 is also doable 92 is not
because it's a little bit of a blunder
so that's why you kind of start closing
down the center you kind of invite the
bishop to come to g4 and then you push
it away
now I see this movie in the chat so I'm
going to say it anyways so right now if
it's black so move black wants to play
c4 and starts to get more space over
here maybe bring the knight over whoops
so stuff like that right so because
black wants this and you can't just play
before because you would lose the c-4
square white plays b3 the idea is quite
simple
he plays Sivir I'm gonna play before you
play b4 I'm gonna play c4 so I'm going
to try and close the Queen side just so
I don't really have a ops anything to
worry about on that side so I can focus
on the King side so why to move what do
you want to do
think about this all the things that I
just said about queenside and watch what
you might want to do in the kingside
thank you so any recommendations and the
candidate moves on what you want to do
or a list of the things you might want
to do TT o TT 0 yup you are correct
so 92 is gonna come up a little bit
later
g 4 is a still premature king lear you
are correct
a 4 so the idea is a 4 is very simple i
the same way that i said i'm gonna try
and close it up i want to close it up i
want to close that Queen side so I can
focus on the King side so thank you for
all of you guys who are contributing so
after a 4 she played a 5
I thought maybe rook c8 might be
slightly better but I would just do the
same 92 and yeah so she put a 5 so now
what do you want to deal with white
keep in mind that white has a slight
advantage right now if I was not a good
move so to all of you who are suggesting
92 and I type 1 and then G for 93 you
are right but you need to prepare better
for it so you can't just leave that mmm
you can't just leave the queenside just
hanging and going off to play the
kingside you got to fix the queenside
first and then move to the kingside so
now the question is how to do it
hi Carter yeah Nixon you're right take
on b5 and if take on before you kind of
do have to exchange the rooks now you
can just take your pawn back and you
have one more pawn on the board right
now so see point 97 now my question is
what do you want to do with whites you
do have advantage quite nicely so how do
you want to use this advantage
yep Ahmadi you're right
yeah free pond is free pond
so now Knight c3 um
I think hmm I was worried if Knight c3
the like something was Roque Wan maybe
to try and exchange the rooks and I
didn't like that idea
so I played Knight a tree but Bishop III
is the strongest one because see after
night a3 you're gonna put a ninety six
and then this night is getting really
strong and protecting everything so
that's why Bishop III would have been
better not if you and I play nice b6 I
can't even consider taking or now I
can't deny that C 3 but this Bishop does
belong on III that's the point
so after Knight b6
I tried Queenie tree because I wanted to
put this Queen on c3 like this and now
she played the 98 so now what do you
want to do with white yeah exactly tto
Bishop e3 not to allow Bishop 96 yep and
yeah those two are doubled baby Queens
you just have to get them to be able to
push a little
so now you want Bishop III I am not
entirely sure if Bishop III is good
right now because well at least let me
just say you have something stronger
yeah G for thank you for all of you who
are saying G for Bishop g6 now you do
your Bishop III you're not gonna let
your opponent's chances to try and like
play f5 maybe because here if not g4 if
you play Bishop III white still does
hold advantage but you have to be
careful cuz this might this night might
want to get jumpy and the bishop might
want to get jumpy from there so that's
why you played g4 so the bishop goes to
cheese 6-9 you get the bishop at so
let's say you got your Bishop outs now
nice a for now what do you want to do do
you want to take that pawn or you want
to take the knight on a four
that is also correct Thank You Bishop
Bishop III does give the black chance to
just plain Bishop takes f3 and mess with
your pawn structure a little yeah thank
you for that
so Jaros loves take what's c4a for
whoo this is nice there are a lot of
suggestions of different takes
so let's say you were to take the pond
if you take the pond taketake there's
nice III it's like a your rook and that
pond USA you play tricky one she would
pick this up and now how do you want to
advance your Queen side so that's a
problem if Queen C for Queen C 494 ninth
Council city ante picks up b5 so that's
why I didn't play my Queen C for cuz the
endgame was actually kind of complicated
so that's why you would go with this up
a for Brooke a for your right this pawn
is a little hanging so you'll come back
and protect it the thing is if right now
after Bishop a4 Bishop takes e4 there
are actually many ways to try and play
this one of them is b6 you play Queen b7
I come back here if you take I just pick
this guy up let me see what other stuff
can it be but the simplest one is also
just like to d2 if you take this I'll
just bring the bishop back so Bishop b4
after Bishop a4 directly doesn't work it
does we can eat four so you guys are
also correct but you just play Knight
teach you and you protect that so now 92
the one thing that you do have to
calculate as Rick takes a three coin a
tree is pretty forced right now c3 how
will you deal with this with as white so
white you move your opponent just play
c3 what do you want to do
p6 well interesting what else I think b6
is a good move
I'm still not saying to move that I
plate so I say p6 I see Roxy 1 but yeah
you're right Thank You Roxy ones not
possible because C takes D 2 and you
don't want that oh I see nikhat Quincy 1
yeah yep you're right
there's b6 and then there is Quincy 1 so
let's look at b6 first and thank you for
answering it and each other in the chat
gets the discussion going very nice yeah
so the problem is if you were to play
Roxy you want the pawn takes your knight
and then if you take rook takes Queen
the pawn becomes a new queen so that's
why Roxy one doesn't work but right now
this me six actually is very interesting
Queen goes to C it's not c1 words
because if take now you just take back
with the bib with the bishop and you
push your rook and next move you have
Queen n7 or if you try to defend it now
Queen 87 if you go up here I believe
just taking here should be sufficient
enough as well so it's very nice you
have those two little baby Queens and
the rook on the seventh rank so it's
it's just it's just really nice right so
b6 also does work so good job on
thinking about b6 nice intermediate move
Queen C one however is what I chose
because I didn't want to risk it and so
I just went with Queen c1 and sheep
let's eat you rook e1 is pretty much
only move over k1 but tricky one makes
more sense right let's say Queen c3 now
Y to move what do you want to do
black is putting some nice pressure so
you got a play quite accurately
well Carter Quincy one-eyed Quincy one
is a good move just saying you I wanted
to show you b6 first before getting into
Quincy one deeply so why to move now
odds
yes you were right p6 let's say
something like h5 coz all right so this
is actually the Rue the game that I
played I did push b6 and she did push h5
so now my question for you is white to
move do you see anything to make the
position more clear J a nice big one
doesn't work just because just takes
back so if you were to play Knight
whoops if you were to play nice b1 just
take and just take and this is very
unpleasant position what black does have
enough compensation and why would you
let your opponent get some don't dodge
your pawn slip away okay no slipping no
sleeping in my classes so nice big one
is interesting definitely but it does
let your opponent slip away a little so
that's why b6 is way more stronger
knowledge 5 so in the game I played g5
but Queen a1 is way way stronger good
job on you guys seeing it so Queen a1
whoa
I was afraid of Queen before then I
wouldn't know what to do and I thought
maybe fruit c1 he just takes and I don't
know what to do now but this is actually
a very good position because now you all
you have to do is get this queen out and
eat this pawn no way for blacks to be
able to keep this pawn so yeah
so after age five I play g5 and yeah
coin a one's pretty cool right f6 take
take now I did the Queen a one Queen
before rook here take take take
so now White's to move how do you want
to start wrapping up keep in mind you
still do have to play very carefully
because there are a lot of chances for
possible perpetual Zoar blunders for you
over here so why to move give me a few
candidate know so how do you want to try
and win
Quinn I ate yeah that Queen eight is
what I did in the game
queen bee queen a2 is also very doable
because you are just defending d5 an
attacking c2 Queen goes here you take a
four not Quincy eight and this is also
very winnable so instead of Queen a two
islands with Queen a eight as most of
you recommended good one um
be careful Burton if B seven night a
strike tonight I'm sorry the night can
just go back to d8 so yeah be careful
with that because if the night just gets
back then you're just give your baby
queen up for nothing so all right so
let's say Queen I ain't check B for now
what do you want to do keep in mind that
this is coming up and your king might be
a little scared
so do you care or do you want you to try
and prevent that or do you want to just
go with the plan and play b7 so my
question is you want to play b7 or if
something else what
Bishop f4 is very interesting Luke g1
[Music]
look she won't kind of scares me because
what if something like check King comes
down and then like something like Queen
f6 going force f3 Raven Queen of five
going first h3 and f3
um Bishop f4 is interesting but I don't
think it actually gets much achieved
because what did you after Queen f5 what
do you want to do with the bishop if you
go to g3 they're always age fours if you
go back to e3 now there's Bishop checks
and this makes it really uncomfortable
so not Bishop f4 what else
so these seven is actually good so the
idea is very simple be seven if you give
me check I'm gonna display this if you
were to play a queen at five hold on let
me repeat this if queen up sticks not
what you do cause if Queen at five you
do have the chance whoops if Queen a
five we do have the chance to take it
over here right so what if Queen goes to
f6 now what do you do keep in mind this
Queen coming to f3 is a problem so Hadi
wants to stop this Queen f3 attack
I still don't see this in the chat
I'm gonna just jump ahead and say it
yeah okay I see it
good from where all right family we had
a hair block all right
glad to be able to hear
I mean glad you guys can hear me so if
Queen f6 Yap Jing Zhi one good one you
are all correct
kingi one is the best one and it kind of
stops all of the ideas and if you
continue giving me checks I can just run
away from here and basically see you
later if Queen of five now let's take
King gage seven so now you have to be
careful what do you want to do now why
it's to move please give me give me a
line on how to not get perpetual because
right now this queen is tree or Queen f3
are the threat trying to perpetual you
so how can you avoid that only few more
moves left in this game
Queen h4 hold on nikhat hold on guys
let's all focus on cleaners for for a
second if Queen h4 what is how can black
actually use this cuz Queen Azshara is a
mistake so how can black use this
mistake
no no one wants to talk about the
mistake
because Queen h4 you give your opponents
a very nice chance to actually slip away
a little that's the thing no it doesn't
stop the fresh paper
the perpetual I can't say perpetual more
than once or twice in a row yeah good
one Newports think the key is this Queen
d1 yep so that's why and now this is a
again perpetual with Queen on f3 so
that's why Queen h4 is a blunder and you
shouldn't play Queen h4 that's why you
should just play king g1 avoid all
checks something like Queen f3 remember
now there is again this idea what
perpetual so how can you stop this three
more moves on my opponents resigned in a
very last position so Queen g5 doesn't
work just because of Queen h3 so I'm
getting a lot of weird Queen g5
suggestions which I not sure why but
Bishop h2 and you are a little whoopsie
whoopsie
so Queen g5 doesn't work guys you gotta
put it more accurate so King g1 Queen f3
how do you want to stop this now Queen
d1 is coming up
yeah rookie one good one good one -
subbu Bakura so a rookie one now all of
the checks and stuff our stops right
queen takes a tree one more tricky move
I know you guys see this one so now this
queen is the problem right how can you
try and kind of drop the Queen let's say
25 where are you going you're getting
mated with like not mated but stuff are
happening with Bishop coming to h2 you
are correct if Queen d1 you can't just
play York f1 whoops honestly if this
happened in the game with Queen d1 I
would just wake win a5 and it's also
holding everything together so Queen h3
now what yeah good one
Queen c8 thank you so the idea of clean
see it is pretty chill
you play Bishop h2 I'm gonna display
King gauge 1 voila yo go Queen h4 all
right who cares I kind of even like try
to outrun you and I'm making the Queen
nice smooth right so yeah this was a
very nice game that I had and my
opponent resides here because um it was
quite the game was really unpleasant and
she's pretty lost anyways so yeah that's
the first game that I wanted to show you
I really liked it it just felt like such
a nice very organized everything was
very organized alright so let's go back
to first move and look at another game
that I played in 2017 I think this
wasn't Portugal the dates sound like
February I think it I was important to
go playing this
thank you it was a nice one so b5 let's
say opponent plays early b5 with Bishop
c5 so after Bishop c5 I I tried the c3
but now you see d4 you can't really play
it because well you don't really want to
lose material early on so I went with d3
it's I think it is possible to do
castellón rooks do you want to but d3
was also my choice because I wanted to
get this night out faster asap getting
this night to decide that it belongs
Bishop g5 Knights coming to g3 and so
now yeah
a4 is the main idea a good one thank you
so now my opponent actually made a
mistake
he played g6 um at the game I remember I
could consider move g5 just because well
I wanted to be sure what I was looking
at and I would definitely go for this
sacrifice which is good here because now
your king is well right now your King
doesn't have a problem and his King is
super weak and this could just be a very
strong attack also nice age 5 coming
clean f3 coming
everything is pointing to the attack so
yeah I was I didn't prepare this before
the game during the game I remember I
was considering it if it was possible
and so anyways he played g6 and so all
right my question for you do you want to
try and do short Castille or do you want
to try and look at slum castle
I do exited this lectures Chesson
psychology is my class I'm here every
week I like it I like showing my games
who doesn't like to show their games am
i right
everything yeah
h-bomb oh yeah in that g5 situation h5
would be very nice push well thank you
for joining us stick sticks stone so
that's the thing with long castles you
wouldn't really it's better not to try
bond Casto because so that was a trick
question if you were to duel on Castle
you would give your opponents your
really nice targets like me 4 C 4 D 5
everything is ready so that's why you
would try to do short Castille and so
right now that's good to castle your
pieces are already in ready to try and
you know push a little bit over here
maybe and so she played Bishop g4 now my
question for you what do you want to do
with white cuz now g5 is a real
possibility like if you were to play
each tree taketake G file is actually
possible now so you gotta be careful
about it so what do you want to do with
White's I don't know if tall would have
done long castle cuz the position is
still like it's good to attack but it's
like you have to try to have somewhat of
a logical attack and do like a risk
assessments before you start plotting
your attack so that's why I'm saying I'm
not really sure if flan castle is a
reasonable
ting f1 yessir stuff ha maybe maybe
windy too so I like your Queen d2 idea
but yeah say it man I think Queenie tree
is better
Queenie tree is the right to move so
Queenie tree good one to subbu Korra
Queenie tree so if let's say Bishop
takes after you now what do you do are
you gonna do some little bit of
sacrificing or take back f3 so what do
you want to do now
keep in mind if you take on a six you
are giving your piece kind of for free
nippur is asking what if black plays c4
are you guys how how's the lighting
situation because some of the comments
are females a little behind all right so
I'm getting comments about I'm getting
chat about the current position alright
great so Bishop f6 is definitely a
possibility but it's not good just Queen
takes and and this is not a very
pleasant end game to playing black it
has the upper hand well I can't start
pushing stuff you know just doing left
and right so Carter yeah if Queen f3 g5
9 to 5
hold on Carter if queen is on f3 so I'm
saying if you take back on f3 g 595 just
take you don't really have Queen and 6
so be careful with these little branders
yeah I hear you but Queen Queen of 6 is
the strongest one because Queen h6 now
you have to think about what if Bishop
g4 right because Bishop g4 is literally
the only move to try and keep the bishop
so let's say black tries to keep the
peace now what do you do with white
that's the main question you have to be
able to answer when you're playing this
Queen e2 Queen e3 idea so now why it's
to play
how can you push for more you just did
sacrifice a full night so you better
have something up your sleeve because if
you played a little chilled out then
your position might get a little bit
uncomfortable so
Queen g5 nope nine to five uh uh King
Lear yep f4 e mod f3 f4 is much stronger
a strange might come out later because
you might fly f4 and then later h3 so f4
is good yeah 9f 5 um I see that you're
going for me so what if just take you
take back you're going after g6 this is
interesting but like something like
Knight g4 and you are busted because you
if you move your queen that happens if
you take take take
I mean it's very it's stup doable and
very nice but your bishop feels a little
too busted well it just feels like there
should be some way to try and get the
bishop so 9 to 5 is interesting but it
doesn't work necessarily TT oh I see if
h3 Bishop e5 Knight hy yeah if Knight
Coast if Bishop goes away there is night
edge 5
what I was thinking about was what if a
street something simple as queenie seven
you take i'll just take over here and
attack this guy queen g5 seems to be the
best one and that's a nice end game but
you can get more out of the position
with f4 so h3 nine to five does those
are all very valid candidates but f4 is
the best one just because after f4
you're giving your opponent more chances
to mess it up let's say opponent tries
to do c4 check now how do you try to win
this
one thing is you can try this d4 tank
and something like h5 if you give me d3
I'll just put my king on each one and
now this is also very deadly attack if
you take I have take this is falling
this is falling this is fun everything
is falling so yeah good one every one d4
kingís one yeah those are those should
be your moves so cheap he plays Queen d7
in the game so let's say Queen e7
White's to move how do you want to win
it it's not a very hard move but I would
prefer to have like you say white does
this black so this is White's best move
and blacks best response to that move is
also Gua so it would be nice to have
like a full move instead of just half a
move
ideally
that five is nice but you have something
stronger you have something way more
decisive first think about checks and
takes so you don't miss takes you don't
mistakes yeah taking on e5 is the best
one yep and taking on e5 you're making
it's clear if you take back I'm gonna
take this I'm gonna go after different
sort of mates d5 or f5 can they thank
you for giving me candidate move yeah
thank you tto d5 Queen e5 you still have
the same Bishop takes here and you are
going after these guys so you are
correct yeah thank you thank you for
giving the here the people at the Chess
Club tanks yeah thank you thank you for
your whoops thank you for your thanks
alright so blacks best move is to play
Queen f8 right so if you don't play
Queen of 8 it is mate left or right
different different kind of mates so you
do have to play Queen f8 and whites best
move is also to exchange it off and now
we get into an endgame with 2 pounds
more where it show very nice everyone's
happy with this end game alright so I am
going to go a little bit faster on the
endgame because I'm still hopeful I
might be able to show you the other game
and it wasn't that there wasn't much
trick in the endgame just I care I try
to do my best to apply pressure to try
and get out of possible tricks and
checks to try to get out of possible
threats whoops reorganizing getting my
rook to the open file still defending
all of my Queen side
going after more ponds now we start to
our pushy pushy no chance of this
Knights getting naughty checks and rook
behind the pond this is going this is
already looking like a danger zone isn't
it I just I was trying to get to the
40th move to get a little bit more time
but this is a very winning position yeah
nobody's happy with this ends game with
black right so if I'm not very
responsive in chat sorry I am trying to
get to the end of this game with trying
to explain it as best as possible so
finally we are reaching a position where
it is ready to push h4 the problem is h4
you would be losing g4 so the main idea
is to try and have a nice break through
like this so if you take I have this
check and I have this killer 95 and if
you don't take well remember how early
on I talked about how Queen e2 you would
be like II remember like early early on
and the Lopes that I was showing with
Queen e2 I was like yeah you see this
there could be B fives and a fours and
stuff yeah so I talked about how it
could be very dangerous for black
alright so this was actually how the
game ended they don't even need to start
pushing I just started picking up more
material and lovely right all right so I
am going to do another game
I won't probably I will not ask for
questions like I won't ask
you to guess a move but feel free to
type in and I will do my best to read
and answer questions so in this other
game I played this in 2017 again and it
was a very nice game can't remember
where but it was again Indra Lopez and I
fully intended to play Queen e2 but my
opponents played this a 66 I played this
with black so I knew what stuff to look
out for and I remembered this Knight g6
I play this as a kid in 2010 it was very
nice and I knew that this idea with h6
and Bishop g5 is black's main idea so I
tried to fight that idea with Knight e3
early on I didn't want to exchange my
bishops so I got to this position quite
pleasant try its Casto you put your
Bishop on b3 going after stuff over here
you could start looking at d5 now you
are clearly looking at this little guy
aren't you
so in the game my opponent played queen
up 6 which was which gave me a little
bit of room to start taking stuff a
little bit because now I got the chance
to take on here and get F 4 and gets
Bishop d4 which is very pleasant right
so I'm gonna back up just a second so I
can show you what would be better for
black so Bishop g4 is actually better
for black and Bishop 3 4 would be
something that would be quite annoying
for me because Bishop h6 doesn't work
here so if you can pause it for a second
I think why it doesn't work
before I show you
so the thing is Bishop h6 there's Bishop
f3 you take it back and black doesn't do
anything with this side black plays
Bishop Knight a5 now if you bring your
Bishop back black actually has advantage
because there are Queen h4 's and 90's
force and everything just jumping to h4
so let's say I took over here you take
over there
and finally after this take this is just
not this is not good for whites white
still has nice pressure but black this
Knight is kind of defending all of it
I'm gonna show you a little bit longer
of what I looked into some of the
possibilities and no any working so it
is working for black not working for
whites
unfortunately so let's back up so Queen
up six now I get this chance to do my f4
I really like playing f4 if you can't
say and Bishop d4 and now he had the
chance to start pushing a little bit so
he tried to play Queen g6 the other
chance was with Queen d7 but I would
definitely play something like h3 and
just take over here and this is lovely
I very much like this position very
pleasant getting my workout getting my
clean out everything is just ready for
more attack so that's probably why he
tried Queen g6 with Knight f6 now it's
White's to move
I would again recommend to pause for a
second so you get your candidate moves
in order before I tell you but so in the
game I played a5 which was a nice move
but Bishop c2 is way way stronger so II
5 is a very decisive
instead of playing like decisive moves
that changes the structure it is a good
idea to try and even psychologically to
just try and come up with more threats
instead of just attack attack because
just the power of the threat is really
really strong also psychologically so
something like Bishop c2 now your
opponent has to like oh my god now what
can I do f5 is coming in five is coming
rook III might be so there are a lot of
things for your opponent's to look out
for but when I played a five I kind of
made it clear like you gotta touch that
Night Man or you have to take that pawn
other if you don't I'm gonna take your
knight so this was a more forceful move
and instead of a tricky move so here's
some psychology for you alright so if
take take this is very pleasant because
the knight can pretty much only go to h7
and still Bishop c5 and I just have so
much nice space the special advantage is
really really clear and quite decisive
so he played mighty four alright so one
last question for you guys what do you
want to do this one I'm actually going
to take a second and catch my breath and
give you guys 10 seconds to figure it
out as well so 94 if you don't play
aggressively Bishop a5 is coming and
just protecting at all and everything is
nice right so how what do you want to do
now how can you start exploiting some
attacks and yeah good one thank you
rookie for queenie for Bishop c2 now you
are going after this week King right 25
Queen D 3 there is
it's there's no way for black to try and
stop this g6e six check and you even
take that one so yeah it was very lovely
I really liked it
this is actually where my opponents
resigned a mr. dumansky for the life of
me I can't remember where I played him I
know it was 2017 but yeah well I hope I
gave you some insights on how to play
Roy Lopez with white just some very
brief with queenie to ideas and some of
the popular sidelines that black could
try that i try look back so yeah i hope
you enjoyed it
glad we've managed to get all three of
the games here if you have questions or
comments or anything feel free to put
them in the comments I'll usually do
check them within the next day and it
would be very nice to see what you think
about all right thank you everyone and
tune in for Dennis burrows
[Music]
[Applause]
you